good morning john one of the things that
we are asked to do as humans is to
understand things that are far outside
of our lived experience like i know what
a mile is i've walked a mile and i kind
of know what a thousand miles is because
i've driven a thousand miles what about
a million miles we kind of break a
little bit outside of our personal
experience but luckily humans have had
some time to develop tools to deal with
this these are important tools to
develop i want to share with you five of
them the earth is around 25 000 miles in
circumference this is luckily almost
exactly 40 000 kilometers both of those
are easy numbers to remember but are
they easy to understand yes kind i can
take the thousand miles that i have
driven and imagine doing that 25 times
that gives me an idea but eventually
this strategy breaks when you have to
start multiplying numbers that on their
own don't make any sense like i don't
understand what a million a thousand
times is because those are both hard to
understand numbers so what do you do
with that our minds have difficulties
distinguishing between percentages and
absolutes going from a hundred to a
thousand is the same percentage increase
as going from a hundred million to a
billion but in absolute terms this is
the difference between 900 and 900
million visualizations can be useful for
helping understand these absolute
differences a stack of a million dollars
is a whole lot smaller than a stack of a
billion dollars visualizations aren't
always easy to find or to create so
let's look at another way that doesn't
require all that work the classic
example here is that a million seconds
is around 11 days and a billion seconds
is around 32 years i know what 11 days
is like and i kind of know what 32 years
is like mostly i know that they are very
different from each other in the same
way the distance from the earth to the
moon is around 250 000 miles and from
the earth to the sun around 93 million
that means nothing to me but if you're
going 70 miles an hour you can get to
the moon in four years and you can get
to the sun and 150. now that still kind
of means nothing to me because i've
never driven a car for four years or 150
years but i get the scale of the
difference but what if i'm less
interested in like the relative
difference between the numbers and more
interested in like the absolute impact
of the numbers often if i actually want
to understand how big a number is i
don't look at the number i look at the
number per unit of relevant things often
times i just like to divide by the
number of people in the u.s like 44
billion dollars is 130 per person in the
u.s including all of the babies 44
million dollars with an m is 13 cents
per human in america so calculating
relative impact gives us some really
good data but not as much as our final
strategy often times absolute numbers
are not particularly useful when it
comes to understanding the world if you
add up local state and federal spending
the government in the us spends around
20 thousand dollars a year per person i
actually have a pretty good conception
of what twenty thousand dollars is but i
don't know what that number means i have
no idea if that is the right number i
could just go on my gut and say that
sounds like a lot or like not enough
like i don't know instead we can compare
and we can see that the us and the uk
and germany and france all spend roughly
the same amount per citizen norway which
has a bunch of money from oil is about
30 000 india is about 1800 these numbers
are just a lot more useful in comparison
to each other than they are in absolute
terms but if you track government
spending per unit of economic production
you actually get a very tight
correlation bigger economies have bigger
state budgets always and there isn't
actually that much variation from
country to country almost as if a lot of
the arguing is about relatively small
policy differences and it might actually
be better to measure other things like
how effective tax policy is at reducing
inequality in a specific country well
done ireland so experiential
extrapolation visualization
understandable comparison relevant
impact calculation and of course more
useful metrics are all excellent
strategies that do different things for
us on our quest to better understand our
world john i'll see you on tuesday